foreign
up next is going to be Jessica in
Louisville Kentucky hi Jessica welcome
to the Ramsay show
hi oh my gosh thank you so much for
taking my call I am the biggest fan and
listen to you every single day and my
three teenage boys
um listen to you in the car and so
they're really learning some great stuff
too
um but just to keep it brief my question
is my husband and I are on baby step six
um we are down to the last 25 000 that
we owe on the mortgage and we have been
hitting it hard like the last four
months gazelle intense and cut out all
spending only buying groceries gas just
the necessities and so my question is
originally we were going to pay it off
May of 23rd June of 2023 we've moved it
up to March of 2023 and now that the end
is getting to the point where it's in
sight
um my son the other night asked if he
could come if we could take him to
Nashville at the end of December for the
Titans Cowboys game and I said the only
way I'm going to Nashville is if I can
go see Dave and do our free screen on
this the stage so I want to know would
it be okay for us to take the remaining
money out of our emergency fund
to pay off the mortgage or should we
just be patient and pay it off March 1st
like we were planning
well it's not an emergency
no okay no we don't we generally use an
emergency fund for emergencies right
absolutely okay how much is in your
emergency fund
so right now we have 37 000 in the
emergency fund and then like just 6 000
and like a sinking fund for cars so that
37 000 and if we did pay off the
mortgage our monthly
um expenses would be right at three
thousand dollars so if we took that down
to like 17 or 20 000 we would still have
that six months and that emergency fund
to cut you know to cover an expense well
if you've got six months in your
emergency fund When the Smoke Clears on
this question then you've got an
emergency fund that's over funded
right it is and with our mortgage it's
it's close to being right it's still a
little bit over but like if we take the
winter household
um we're north of 200 000 probably 250
with my side hustle I would use the car
money in a heartbeat
okay okay we'll just delay buying a car
we'll get the house paid off because
you're really focused on the house
payoff I'm willing to do that
um and I'm willing to bring the
emergency fund down as long as it's not
dangerous I just don't want to invite
Murphy because when you don't have an
emergency fund you're sending an
engraved invitation to crap to come
visit you
oh and he's shown up ever since we got
really aggressive like we had a 2700 car
repair we had an unexpected water so
yeah so if you have three of those and
then you end up making 200 000 a year
with a paid for house and you're broke
and can't eat I don't like that plan
okay so you gotta you gotta stay above
that right but if you're sitting there
with 20K
and you can still make it and you use
the car money does that sound okay to
you yeah absolutely my first thought is
yeah what if your roof leaks what if you
know the car breaks down on the way to
Nashville there's so many things that
could happen so yeah you just you just
don't want to go down too close you
don't want to violate where you're below
the three to six months of expenses
guideline because you're just asking for
crap you know and if you can do it and
not get below that then yeah and I'm
definitely using the car money that's a
no-brainer but I think you're gonna make
it I got a feeling I got a feeling
you're focused well you've got such a
great income it's like I think if you
all pretty aggressive between now and
then you got a good shot yeah and by the
way we don't recommend it's not our
program to be that intense when you're
at baby step six but it's okay if you
want to be